Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an American horror-thriller film
called “13 Sins”. Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie begins in Perth Australia. Professor
Edgar Solomon is welcome to make a speech in front
of several people at a party. He recites a kid’s
poem about a rabbit and a bear but the crowd gets
uncomfortable when the poem gets inappropriate.
He is stopped by a woman beside him who is as
surprised as everyone else. Edgar apologizes
and cuts one of her fingers off using a knife.
Her screams make everyone else run away while
the professor collects the finger in a tissue.
The security guard asks him to put his hands
up and when he doesn’t oblige, he is shot dead.
With his last strength, Edgar tries to get
to his mobile phone but is unsuccessful.
Elsewhere, Salesman Elliot Brindle lives in
New Orleans, Louisiana. He and his fiance are
expecting to have a baby soon and are
about to get married in a few days. At
such an important point in his life, Elliot is
told that he is fired. According to his boss,
he is too much of an empath to be in sales.
Following that, Elliot goes home to his
mentally challenged younger brother Michael.
Michael is his biggest responsibility because
he pays twelve hundred dollars monthly for his
outpatient care. Now that he is unemployed,
Michael is at risk of being sent to a mental
institution that he dreads. After the encounter,
Elliot drives to his abusive and racist father
Samson to ask for help. However, he finds out
that Samson has lost all his retirement funds
and will now have to move with them.
At night, Elliot is alone in the
car when he is troubled by a fly.
He gets a call from someone who claims that he
has been selected for a one-of-a-kind game show
that could make him a lot of money. At first,
Elliot thinks that the person is a scammer.
He is about to end the call but stops when the
initiator recites all of Elliot’s family history.
He seems to know everything significant that has
happened in Elliot’s life since his childhood,
including the details about his mother’s fatal
car accident. At last, he also talks about the
fly that has been bothering him recently. Elliot
is left speechless. The man claims that if he
kills the fly, a thousand dollars will be sent
to his bank account. Without thinking much of it,
Elliot swats the fly and kills it. Seconds later,
a notification informs him that his bank account
has been credited with a thousand dollars. He
quickly gets out of the car to check if someone is
spying on him. Looking around, he realizes that he
is in fact alone, but if that is true there is no
way to explain the money in his bank account.
The person says that his next challenge is to
swallow the fly for exactly three thousand six
hundred twenty-two dollars. Elliot quickly gets
in the car and rushes back home. He checks his
computer and sees that the thousand dollars are
still in his account. He is in need of money, and
also wants to check if the initiator is legit.
Hence, he eats the dead fly reluctantly. He
yet again gets the phone call from the person
congratulating him for completing the second
task. The money is soon transferred to his
bank account. Confused by all this, Elliot
inquires if he is being watched even in his home.
The voice says that he can get his privacy back
if he wishes to but that would mean he would be
disqualified from the game. Following that, he is
briefed about the rules of the game. Elliot will
have to complete a series of thirteen challenges,
each of which will result in greater rewards. If
he fails to complete any of them, interferes in
the game, or reveals the game to anyone else,
he will lose all the money, including any he
has already won. Since he has completed two
challenges, he has only eleven more left. If he
wants to continue the game, he is asked to say
“I will dance with the Golden Toad”. Elliot does
as said and is registered as a contestant.
The next day, he is in a park with Shelby and her
parents impatiently waiting for the next call.
Some minutes later, he is told that the third
challenge for five thousand dollars is to make
a child cry. He excuses himself and starts looking
for the perfect child. A little girl comes running
to him, giving him the perfect opportunity. He
tells her that her parents are going to leave her
in an orphanage and makes her cry. The child runs
to her parents while he receives the cash prize.
He quickly gets in the car with Shelby to
drive away as the parents yell curses at him.
Following that, the pair goes to the church to
pick up Elliot’s father. He gets a call again
and is told that for the fourth challenge, he
should burn a nativity scene handcrafted by
blind kids for the church. When no one is looking,
Elliot brings the structure outside and burns it.
The fire accidentally spreads around the
church and gets uncontrollable. He quickly
runs away with his family after ringing the
fire alarm. Moments later, ten thousand dollars
is credited to his account. Not long after, he
gets the next challenge and is asked to follow
a homeless person by the side of the road.
In the police station, the little girl’s parents
have come to report the incident. At the same
time, the homeless person also arrives there.
Detective Chilcoat is told that someone stole
the homeless person’s clothes and belongings.
When the sketches of the felon are made, they
realize that the person who stole the clothes,
burned the church, and troubled the girl is the
same. Elliot is now in challenge six. He is asked
to take a man from a specific apartment out for
coffee. He believes that the challenge is too easy
but he soon realizes the catch. The person he is
taking out is lying dead in the bathtub. With no
way out, he sprays a freshener all over the corpse
to hide the smell. He then dresses it and drags it
out on a wheelbarrow to the nearest diner. The
waitress comes to take his order and doesn’t
think much about the dead guy because his face
is hidden with a hat. Elliot is given a deadline
to complete the mission, hence the slow waitress
annoys him. Just then, a group of policemen enters
the diner for lunch. When the coffee doesn’t
arrive till the last second, Elliot snatches a
cup from the policemen’s table. The challenge is
completed but he is in trouble with the police.
They ask him to come out to talk but he sees that
they were drinking on duty and calls them out.
At last, he manages to run away while arguing.
He gets a call from the initiator who is impressed
by his skills. Hence, he jumps him directly to
the eighth challenge. But Elliot’s happiness
doesn’t last for long when he is informed that
he has left his library card in the diner. The
police will soon find him but if he completes
all challenges, the initiator will get him free
no matter what. Now, his only way to a free life
is to complete the challenges. Following that,
a van picks Elliot up and brings him somewhere
for his next mission. Back in the diner,
the policemen find the corpse and start to
investigate. Detective Chilcoat sees a strange man
talking to the waitress. The waitress says that
the man was inquiring about Elliot. The detective
starts to follow the guy to the trailer and finds
that he has been investigating the game. He has
found out where it first started and what happens
to the people who play it. However, no information
about the initiator is available. In the meantime,
Elliot is taken to a room where he meets his high
school bully John. It turns out his next challenge
is to cut off John’s arm. He doesn’t have to do it
forcefully because John is volunteering to get
his arm cut for money. When Elliot hesitates,
the guy reminds him of all the ways he was
bullied, making him do it. After cutting it off,
he drives John to the hospital. He gets two
hundred fifty thousand dollars for the mission.
Then, he drives to his practice dinner for his
wedding. His next mission is to trash the party in
front of everyone and urinate in one of the flower
arrangements. The police arrive there looking
for Michael accusing him of public nudity. Elliot
takes the opportunity to help Michael and distract
the police by trashing the party. He breaks all
the cutleries and pees on the flowers. This way,
Shelby thinks that he is doing it for his brother
when in reality he is doing it for the challenge.
He manages to run away from the security but
his next challenge is to surrender himself.
He reluctantly goes back and is arrested. In
the police station, he is interrogated about
everything he did throughout the day. When he
is accused of things he didn’t do, he finds out
someone else is also playing the games. When no
one is watching, he breaks the bottom of the chair
and uses it as a weapon to hold a policeman
hostage. At last, he jumps off the window and
lands on a dumpster. He loses his phone in the
chase and has no way to contact the initiator.
Just then, he notices a homeless woman walking
by and assumes she is sent by the initiator.
The two enter a trailer nearby.
Somewhere else, Detective Chilcoat finds the
conspiracy theorist, Vogler, he was looking for.
It turns out that his wife had played the game
some years ago and died while playing it.
Since then, Vogler has been trying to find
the initiator. Back in the trailer, the woman
asks Elliot to hang a clothes hanger as his next
mission. He does it but soon finds out the string
goes across the road that a group of youngsters
is riding their bikes on. If the string stays
there, it will cut their heads off. Elliot quickly
removes the string not wanting to kill people
for the challenge. However, the second person
who is also playing the game ties another string
across the road and brutally kills the youngsters.
Seeing their decapitated bodies, Elliot refuses
to continue the game. He runs behind the second
player to stop him as well. The man gets in a van
and drives away while being followed by Elliot.
The initiator calls Elliot on a phone that he had
stolen earlier to tell him about his last mission.
He says that the last mission is the same for all
players; he has to kill one of his family. Elliot
ignores the call, not wanting to continue the
game. To his surprise, he sees the van parked in
front of his apartment building. When he goes in
he finds his father in the living room and Michael
in the bathroom. He puts two and two together and
figures out that the second player is Michael.
Michael still wants to play the game and is
ready to shoot their father dead to win it.
To their surprise, the father claims
that he had also played the game
many years ago. He won after killing their
mother. The brothers are left speechless.
Elliot gets ready to kill him but the father
cuts his own throat to keep them from winning.
Elliot wants to end everything but Michael points
his gun at him to win the game. While trying to
make him understand, Elliot accidentally shoots
Michael. Even then, the younger brother doesn’t
give up. He stabs Elliot but dies in the
process. Elliot has finally completed
all thirteen challenges. He limps away from the
house while being watched by Detective Chilcoat.
We find out that the detective is also working
for the game. He has killed Vogler because he
was too close to finding out about the initiator.
Detective Chilcoat goes inside the house to light
Michael and his father’s body on fire to erase the
evidence. Before he can, Elliot arrives there and
shoots him dead. In the last scene, he calls
Shelby and tells her he is fine. She informs
him of a phone call she received that morning
asking her to eat a fly. Elliot freezes in shock
but Shelby says that she declined the offer.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.